a rare break of cross-party unity on the
week of International Women's Day when
the long awaited domestic abuse bill was
introduced to Parliament almost a third
of women will have experienced domestic
abuse almost certainly someone that you
know it starts slowly a few emotional
knocks alternated with the romantic
gushes and promises of everlasting love
one of them is the MP for Canterbury
rosie da field who moved the house of
coins to tears last october when she
spoke of her own experience months later
she welcomes the reintroduction of the
bill I think all sides of the house so
all parties are welcoming it because it
was all interrupted by the general
election in December and we've all just
been waiting to get on with things and
we have got that cross party agreement
so I think you know it should get hurry
to the house quite quickly what does
that Beltran do I think it protects
women and the most vulnerable situations
and strengthens the protections around
them so women who are homeless I'm
really hoping that that is a protection
that's put in the bill women who are
vulnerable financially Victor Atkins and
I were talking at an event about
protecting women from financial abuse
the other day I know she's really keen
on pushing that I think it's just
flagging up that women need the extra
layer of care and protection if they are
in a really vulnerable domestic violence
situation if there anything that you
want it to do that it doesn't I think
we're very keen on my side to make sure
that women are protected when they go to
refuges from them being closed down
because there's not enough money so the
government were talking about giving
more money to refuges and more money for
those services so we need to make sure
that they are protected do you think
that sometimes with domestic abuse and
domestic violence there's some
misconceptions yeah about what can
happen and also here it can happen -
absolutely I mentioned in my speech that
it isn't just those soap opera families
it's not a particular class or a
particular kind of person that's
vulnerable to domestic violence or
domestic abuse and I guess the victims
find themselves becoming more isolated
abuse isn't it to cut people off from
their family and their friends to stop
their mobile phone use sometimes even in
the worst cases to lock them in the
house and I guess the controlling
behaviour as well and the abuse it can
be violent but it doesn't always have to
be fight yeah of course it can be
violent
you'll know about that and women that
will go to the doctor about something
might have those things those signs
might be picked up but if it's just more
about control or financial abuse than
those things aren't necessarily going to
be spotted and why did you decide to do
your speech I think because in
Parliament we talk about statistics and
we talked about we're kind of removed
from the things we talked about and
debates like today's give us an
opportunity to say we're ordinary women
as well we're ordinary people and those
issues affect us as well and we're there
we're on your side first people who
haven't heard your speech and obviously
wouldn't be led by you on this but what
happened to me I ended up reuniting with
someone just after the election that I'd
had a really nice relationship with for
a couple of years and he came back into
my life saying you know I know you're
the same person and I really want to
support you and when you're just
propelled into the limelight without any
kind of preparation I didn't have a clue
I was going to win or be an MP that old
familiar kind of thing was really
appealing I thought this is someone who
knew me and wanted to date me when I was
a teaching assistant is going to be safe
and he made all the right noises instead
of the right things quite shortly after
we moved in together he was proposing
and I felt kind of safe and everything
else around me was so kind of new and
strange but it didn't take long for me
to see a completely different side to
him yeah violent tempers constant
threats he was going to leave if I
disagreed with him at the drop of a hat
he was gonna go abroad he was gonna just
leave I was thinking about a minute I
hadn't done anything differently all
wrong and it just stepped up so the
arguments would be I don't know maybe
once a month at first and then it got
very quickly to the stage where I
couldn't say or do anything without
being kind of interrupted and I got to
the stage where I didn't want to go home
and speak at all because every single
word I uttered would be interrupted with
some kind of barrier or some kind of
argument and it just felt exhausting it
sounds quite exhausting yeah was it
controlling yeah I felt that my opinions
weren't allowed to be voiced you know
I'm a politician we have a lot of
is interesting you say you made you feel
safe at the beginning entering pollen
for the first time how did you make you
feel more scared of going home than I
was staying in the library working to
1:00 2:00 in the morning I didn't want
to go home and a couple of times I phone
him I know now it was to test the water
to see how things were at home and I
would phone on the pretense of saying do
I need to pick up milk or dinner or
whatever and kind of just in a few
syllables it would be obvious that
actually it wasn't a great idea me going
home so occasionally I didn't at all
when was it you realize that this was a
are you in a bad situation that you
needed to get out on people around me
were noticing more and more that I was
kind of more withdrawn my team at work
were just more uncomfortable when he was
around my mum works for her for a rape
charity actually and she was kind of
saying I'm not really comfortable with
what I'm hearing and I'd kind of deny it
make excuses but then there were days
where you know like I said the audience
were once a month or so and then they
were kind of every single day and I was
so tired and I felt like there was no
[ __ ] of light left there was no oxygen
I couldn't say a single thing and I
thought I can't live like this a minute
longer mm-hmm so yeah and how did you I
took a few weeks and I thought I came
what am I going to do and I didn't want
to win things I mean I absolutely adored
this girl we were engaged and you know
he would tell me how much he loved me
all the time so it's kind of unraveling
those mixed messages as well I didn't
feel loved but he was telling me how
much he loved me
and we were still quite romantically
involved and dated and things but yeah I
thought I can't take this anymore you
just feel like you're on the verge of
tears all the time I'm not soft at all
actually I appear like that but I'm
pretty tough I've been a single mom for
a long time and he would just make me
feel like I just wanted to cry every
time I walked in the front door which
was ridiculous and how do you feel now
um
relieved but still kind of not entirely
over it have to be honest mmm
but that's what broke into sales well
and you kind of you know you talk about
it or you get sort of flashbacks of
certain conversations and it was really
and at the time I couldn't necessarily
cry I didn't want him to see that he'd
hurt me so much so I would just withdraw
withdraw so now I feel freer to just
face up to what happened and your
story's definitely gonna help a lot how
the women it seems to understand I hope
so yeah yeah yeah and you must be so
pleased to see the legislation going
through if there are other things that
you'd like to see change it means that
we can have that conversation it means
that women know that we're taking it
seriously do you think the areas are
worried that you know sometimes domestic
abuse hasn't been taken seriously enough
yeah I think it was seen as a kind of
fringe thing you know stop it we're
telling men just stop it and it is
mostly men I know that men are also
victims of this but just everyone
there's no excuse we're gonna make it
the law that you know you have no hiding
place thank you very much thank you